on monday mexico supreme court
decriminalized cannabis use
today is a historic day for freedom
after a long road the supreme court
recognizes the right to the recreational
use of marijuana
but although lighting up is now not
illegal it's not exactly legal either
there is still a gray area because there
is no legislation the supreme court does
not legislate they are only crossing out
unconstitutional
articles in other words the supreme
court can only decriminalize pot
they can't come up with laws to regulate
its use that's a job for the senate and
congress
and one they've been trying to do for
the last couple of years shuttling
legislation back and forth between them
that would set rules for consuming
growing and selling
but they've never quite got it approved
the supreme court's decision will push
them to get on with that
now it's up to mexico's politicians both
here in the senate
and also in the house of congress to
finally get the legislation done
to regulate this new market and make
sure that it's a responsible one
rather than dissolving into chaos
at the moment the supreme court decision
only allows marijuana use
and with a permit a whole lot more needs
to be decided
how would a market to sell pot work how
to balance corporations and mexican
farmers
the politicians are still pondering
those questions
but this is a step forward john holman
al jazeera
mexico city